foreign
CBS deals and this morning we have
products that might make your day
brighter tastier and a little easier in
all exclusive low prices so to start
shopping
scan that QR code on your screen or
visit cbsdeals.com our lifestyle expert
Ashley Bellman joins us with more good
morning good morning I get so excited I
get flustered because I want to get to
you I know it's because we have really
good stuff cbsdeals.com for all of it
but let's talk about this whoosh powered
ear cleaner you never knew you needed it
and now is the time to try it for 45.49
this is going to prevent that wax
buildup you could do it at home easily
I'm not going to do it here because I
don't want to make a mess but you just
stick it in your ear and this is going
to have three jet streams you can adjust
the pressure and it's going to feel like
a nice therapeutic massage for your ear
make sure that water comes out like you
see there but it is 35 off today it's
going to stay charged for a long time
you can keep it in the shower my husband
is always claiming that he can't hear me
because he has wax buildup I think it's
10 years of marriage but either way this
is what he is getting for Father's Day
so that's that ditto ditto okay so next
up we have the solo wave one I have been
using this for years it's an at-home
facial tool I got it for a lot higher of
a price the deal today is so good 68.99
you just put it up to your face it's
going to give you microcurrent
technology red light therapy reduce fine
lines and wrinkles give you an immediate
glow five minutes a day three times a
week this is a game changer and it's
warming so I like to use it before bed
because it just kind of puts me in that
Zen going to sleep mode is that why your
face is so bright yeah that and a little
help from the Glam Squad but honestly it
works and especially when I'm not
wearing makeup I love the way my skin
looks okay aquaguard anyone jumping into
the ocean or the pool this summer this
is going to protect your hair no matter
what your hair type is from those
harmful chemicals those harsh chemicals
that make you have that frizzy stringy
for me I have blonde highlights green
hair if I jump in the chlorine so you
put this on there's lots of different
products go to cbsdeals.com there's one
that you put on generously to protect
your hair before you jump in the pool
that's yeah girls put it in dry or damp
and then we have post Pool Products as
well so shampoo conditioner the deals
start at 14.99 up to 36 percent off such
good savings I would say get one of each
because this you're going to run through
all of this this looks like something
this is aqua pure so I you know you're
always supposed to wash your fruits and
vegetables you put this device into a
tub of water into a bowl put your fruit
in there and you will see all of the
gross things the chemicals the
pesticides a lot of it am I supposed to
press that but you press the button and
it's for five minutes you keep the fruit
submerged in the Basin of water and then
this one's already been working but oh
it has yeah and then you can see it here
so then so then you go go to rinse then
you rinse it right after you will know
99 of the bacteria the pesticides the
chemicals are going to be off you could
eat your fruit
with a peace of mind and you know I'm a
germaphobe so this is very important for
me I can't believe I didn't have this
until now 41 off 59 today and you're
telling me I didn't have to get my hand
I'm sorry
yes no we we started yeah we started the
process before we came on air but oh I
love it I love it I love it thank you so
much Ashley of course of course we
partner with all of these companies to
get these deals so to buy anything you
saw today just scan that QR code on your
screen or head on over to cbsdeals.com